good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Thursday it's
thuma Thursdays here at the morning
toast because today's lead sponsor is
thuma but we're not ready for that yet
okay we'll ease our way into the thuma
of it all so exciting that it's Thursday
congratulations everyone muzzle
we did it it's so exciting
and it's a big deal it's just a big deal
no matter where you are who you are what
you're going through
um it's Thursday unless you live in
Australia to which I believe it's Friday
so I'm even happier for you even better
we're even better huge in Australia
that's like what happens when you have a
global brand
yeah you make it to Australia 100
what's new with you on this fine morning
so much I wanted to share
um like a really scary situation that
happened to me yesterday one because
it's crazy and two because I feel like I
wish I'd listen to a podcast where
somebody documented this experience so I
would have been less scared and known
that like it's not normal but like it's
it just happens it happens
so yesterday I went downtown for I told
you Theo's bark Mitzvah I did a sponsor
uh partnership with Amazon and we threw
a little party for Theo it was so fun it
was all the way downtown and the streets
are on fire because of the UN General
Assembly the president is in town so I
took the train and I'm on the train and
I don't have a seat
and which I like hate but whatever like
I lived and then we stopped somewhere
busy and the train kind of cleared out
so uh we walked over to the seats that
had opened up and on my way over there I
banged my Funny Bone which like hurt but
it wasn't the end of the world
so I realized like 25 seconds later like
my elbow is still hurting me
and I turned to my side to chat with the
person I'm sitting next to not a
stranger to someone I know and as I'm
turning I hit my Funny Bone again and
I'm like oh my God I hit it again and
this time it hurt like like true pain
not like the tingling sensation of a
funny bone that like makes you giggle
true
to my Core Physical [ __ ] pain
and I said I was like oh my God that
hurts so bad I actually feel nauseous
and once I said that
I entered into like a medical crisis I
had a full-blown
20 SEC no two minute I think the whole
thing probably lasted two minutes two
minute panic attack
I thought I was gonna vomit I got so
nauseous I thought I was gonna faint
like I didn't even have enough energy to
sit up straight I was like I might have
to lay on the floor of the Subway
because I'm not okay I started profusely
overheating when the subway was actually
freezing I was sitting under an air
conditioning vent that's why I chose the
seat
I started to drip with sweat like I had
done six Soul cycle classes in a row
beads of sweat coming out of every
orifice of my body my clothes became
immediately drenched I put my hand
behind my neck it I walked I took out my
hand you would have thought I had just
washed my hands before I dried them it
was so crazy I'm freaking out I'm like
panicked I'm like what is going on I
feel nauseous I think I'm gonna faint oh
my God I'm like embarrassed everyone's
looking at me sweating sweating sweating
sweating sweating I started like just
focusing on my breathing
oh
thank God I had a ponytail and water I
literally just started like chugging
water put my hair up I'm sweating like
I've never sweat in my life
focusing on my breathing all in all the
whole ordeal lasted two minutes and like
I started to come out of it and I still
didn't feel 100 but I was not as bad as
I was and by the time I got all the way
down to Canal Street like I had fully
recovered I was just like shook by this
thing
and it was kind of all I could think
about like for the rest of the day and
then last night I
um I had some girlies over because we're
going to talk about how we got a
screener to watch luckiest girl alive
you watched it last night I watched it
last night I invited some people over
and I was telling everyone about my
treacherous day and Dana one of your
best friends from college co-host of the
redheads sure you all know Dana her
author of The Beautiful hit song My Judy
Brown
her face like drains its blood she's
like Claudia I'm like what she's like
the same thing happened to me last week
I was freaking out and it was so weird
is that it happened to her on the train
too she was going to Amy Schumer at
Madison Square Garden and they got off
on Penn Station and she like Snapped her
ankle and after that happened she
proceeded to have like a full-blown
three-minute panic attack she laid down
on the floor of Penn Station
she told her husband that go go find me
some cold water like I'm gonna lay here
on the floor
and it like was a couple of minutes and
then she came out of it and she like
when I tell you the validation I felt
knowing somebody else had had that
experience because I was like I'm
medically not okay
she told me what it was called hold on I
texted her last night so I could Google
like what the name was it's called
vasovagal syncope synops syncope
I Googled it it's like when you know
like something happens to your body that
just causes your body to go into like
fight or flight mode and like your blood
pressure just drops immediately and you
feel like you're having an anxiety
attack you are profusely sweating you
are nauseous you think you're gonna
faint
and my elbow still hurts like really bad
I don't know what I did to like bang it
up so bad it wasn't even that hard of
like a kerfuffle
I just want anyone to know like if
something like that happens to you like
it's normal and you really in order to
get rid of it immediately you have to
clench your fists and like move your
legs and they say even singing can help
just raise raises your blood pressure
not the same if I had known I would have
become a Subway performer there were
nights of endless pleasure
yeah they see this girl she's on the out
all of a sudden she's brought back to
life herself back she sings herself back
to like life now I just want to say I'm
sorry that that happened it was so scary
and could it have happened on like a
worse place like a panic attack on the
subway like so many people so far from
home oh and by the way as it was
happening was like one of those
situations where you're stuck between
stations because like the train in front
of you is being slow so I'm like feeling
a little claustrophobic like it was
[ __ ] horrible
yeah so overall how was the subway fine
it wasn't the Subway's fault that I'm
literally unwell
I don't know I feel like there was three
factors in both your and Dana situations
like one the pain the injury cause the
this anxiety but I think the fact maybe
that it happened underground
exacerbated anxiety yeah I think if I
had been at home I wouldn't have been so
scared like I think the anxiety part of
my anxiety attack might have been like a
little lessened but that's just what
happens when your blood pressure drops
like really dramatically
um and I think I would have been
freaking out no matter where I was but I
think yes the fact that I wasn't at home
I was in a large crowd I was underground
I was like stuck between stations I was
like thinking of maybe getting off on
the next station but like I could not
[ __ ] move
yeah well all I have to say also is
thank God Dr Theodore for Chemin was
with you yeah because if this was a
medical crisis he would have known one
no thank God I wasn't alone because like
I was like panicked that like Theo would
jump out of my seat and run off at the
next station thank God I wasn't alone
like I was I would have been so so
scared if I was alone because like I
just that's really I just like shoved
Theo and Lizzie's lap and like I just
sat there like
focusing on myself
but if I had to care for another like
living being on my own I would have
freaked out
yeah it was like seriously top 15
scariest moments of my life
wow so that's a thing by the way like
sometimes you can just randomly injure
yourself and then have a panic attack
and they say when you break a bone you
know that it's really broken because
right after you break it you get very
nauseous
that's like a thing
so I was like did I break my elbow so
many new things
no it was horrible
but I'm okay
and Theo was bark mitzvot at the end of
this treacherous Church yeah so all of
that I just think that's kind of like
the Jewish way of existing like in order
to celebrate a like a simcha A
celebratory moment you have to suffer
you have to know you have to save data
no straw 100 so it was a very Jewish Day
Theo's bark mitzel was amazing Amazon
private Brands through a real Soiree all
of his doggy friends came out all of his
human friends came out it was A
Beautiful Affair really stunning and I
have a cute Vlog coming to my Instagram
soon so don't forget to follow me on
Instagram
and you were shopping the office for
your boy shipping Knuckles Left Right
Center knockless everywhere
I missed that dude you know I need to
get my Dew pillow it's across oh my Brew
pillow tomorrow is oh boy right over
there
so Brew is very proud of his cousin he
hopes one day to follow in his bark
Mitzvah footsteps just the uh does Bruno
want to does Bruno when the time comes
does he want to read from the Torah
he does because he wants to challenge
himself yeah and he's interested in
talmudic learnings and he thinks that
doing that for his bar mitzvah might be
the perfect for it and two the ribbon
the rabbinical do you ever think back on
things you did like when you were
younger and you're just in awe of like
the fact that you did that
yes I one of the things that like I'm in
awe of is the fact that like when we
were all about mitzvahed for women it's
optional to do like a Torah portion not
only we did a Torah portion we did a
half Torah and we did a MAF tier like we
did the whole thing we studied with a
rabbi for weeks and months leading up
and honestly like if you put that [ __ ]
in front of me right now I couldn't read
it
no but yeah you study for me some months
you listen to it on tape so that
cassette pretty much like memorize it
yeah and it's pretty cool it was cool it
looks pretty I'm like proud that we did
that
yeah and also we use Trope in everyday
life 100 literally
I'm gonna explain what Trope is but what
we do and maybe if we hadn't been
batmitz fit in that way we wouldn't know
to do it but like Trope is like the tune
of something so just like it's pretty
cool like I could do hey Claudia right
like and it would be like in the Torah
in Hebrew there's these things called
neku don't it's basically like
punctuation they're like these little
symbols under different letters and
under different words that represent a
certain tune a certain Trope that show
you how you should sing that so there's
like a three dot thing under the word
like
uh
what can I think of a word Omer so you'd
have to be like oh mayor like and
anytime you see those three dots it's
close yeah Jacqueline it depends what
like letter in the Hebrew word the
nekudot is under it's under that's so it
either could be Jacqueline or Jacqueline
you know
sorry sort of yes it was a lot of work
anyways we use tropin everything so
that's something that we learned for
robot Mitzvah is that we carry with us
shout out Rabbi platten I didn't realize
we don't even realize how much it's a
part of our life so true so true and
those little cassettes we would like
tape our lessons with the rabbi and then
we'd have to go home and listen to it
and like it was torture like it was so
much work
but anything worth having
like your Womanhood right being a woman
of God
we're such women of God
speaking of Jew and believe in God
she's not a Christian
um speaking of the truckers for God have
arrived
um speaking of
God we are entering the time of year
filled with Jewish holidays so just
warning like the next couple of weeks
are sparse wow the God is really showing
up the truckers for god
um there are kind of sparse we've got
Rosh Hashanah which is the beginning of
the new year which is a good one you
know food friends family holiday Faith
the many of Yom Kippur which is the bad
one it's the day of fast the day of
atonement it is the worst day of the
year
um I'm so not looking forward to that to
everyone's breath like
except
this is the first yomki program in like
a hardcore like reading cycle and I do
feel as though reading is like a really
helpful way to pass time
yeah because you're not gonna watch TV
right or no
yeah no TV no phone no food
no fun
no drink that's the hard part like some
people don't even brush your teeth like
if you're uber religious and I don't do
that not because I'm not religious but
because I cannot and I'm literally gonna
like suck the water out of all the
bristles on my toothbrush when I wake up
yeah oh even though
even though um getting an IV like the
week of fasting really really helps I
don't know if that's cheating but like I
think I'm gonna do it
do it that's not cheating okay I'm gonna
call Ivy drips in schedule one like for
two days before
I'm just gonna Juliana drink a lot of
water you gotta drink a lot of water
that's true that's Trope Trope trope
um so yeah that's coming up for us so if
there's anything you know with the
Jewish New Year if I did anything to
upset anyone this year
um that's on you and you should stop
being so sensitive
yeah no enough I did offend or upset
anyone like deal with this you know what
it's like the time of year where you're
supposed to kind of like make amends
with everyone so I just want to say like
if something I did or said or you know
acted in a way this year that kind of
bothered anyone or hurt them to their
core like that's a hundred percent on
you not on me and I'm not sorry
no no no no no no and like you should
kind of no no you should spend this time
of year like reflecting on why you are
the Way You Are
yeah
I agree no but those 10 days in between
Rosh Hashanah and Yom Kippur we always
tell you guys they're like the most
critical 10 days in the Jewish calendar
it's when the book of life and the book
are being sealed for the upcoming year
so we're on our best behavior you will
not touch me talking no no I don't think
we're gonna be able to work I'm not I'm
not even gonna shadily send like a a
Instagram story that I'm finding yeah
yeah no that's going to be tough not
doing it's gonna be tough to do our jobs
appropriately like if we can't talk [ __ ]
yeah so if the episode's like
the 10 episodes after next week are bad
like just know it's a it's a faith thing
if you think they're bad you're
anti-semitic and and we're gonna we'll
get back to normal after Yom Kippur they
also do say like if you pass away
between Rosh Hashanah and Yom Kippur
like the two big holidays during those
10 days where like the Book of Life is
being inscribed like you're an extremely
special person and not to make
everything about us but our dad did die
in those 10 days and that's like one of
the few things that brings me solace
yeah I think they say straight to heaven
straight to heaven like no matter what
the [ __ ] you did in your life like
heaven
foreign
nice it's a good life honestly like
if I could schedule like when I'm gonna
die like I would request those days you
would do it right before oh yeah yeah no
for sure because that's the way I don't
have to live through another Yom Kippur
yeah so it's a little bit of your Jewish
facts daily
it's a very Jewish season coming up so
it's top of mind it's a very Jewish
season coming up so Hava Nagila Havana
Gila
to life
but let's not so yes let's not Mar the
mood with Yom Kippur talk no no we still
have like 15 days and we're gonna make
the most out of all every single one
today we've got a great episode we have
the Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
recap which I have a lot to say on we
both watch [ __ ] and I don't think we can
necessarily recap it but let's just
quickly talk about the fact that Netflix
was generous enough to hand over a
screener to luckiest girl alive for us
we both watched it last night we're not
gonna like spoil it we're not gonna say
how we thought because it's not fair but
you guys know that's Jackie and I's like
favorite book of all time we've been
talking about the movie being made since
its Inception Mila Kunis is the star
Connie Britton is in a Connie Britain
was amazing and um yeah we got to see it
last night and we're gonna be annoying
about it
yeah it's very close to the book I I
thought and I thought it was like 99
perfectly cast and perfectly set up like
the New York City yes the Nantucket
scenes like the settings were gorgeous
the brently school like everything is
really how I imagined it from the book
and I don't know that I've had that
experience from a book to movie that
I've seen recently yeah that's fair
that's fair I don't want to give any
thoughts like I want to wait till
everyone sees it because I think that's
annoying and I don't want to put
anything in anyone's brain like it was
so good or so bad like because then I'll
influence if you loved the book watch
the movie and then we'll talk about it
it comes out I think on September 29th
or 30th so next week on Netflix on
Netflix not sponsored but like thanks
for the screeners and I'm super
appreciative and I I would love some
more
nothing makes me feel more special
there's only ever gonna if there's only
ever gonna be one like I'm so glad that
it was our favorite 100 of all time and
that like someone there like saw us and
knew that like that book is important to
us
I also um nothing makes me feel cooler
or more famous and special than getting
a screener
they're hard to come by I mean some
shows just like give them yes like they
can't give them away fast enough please
watch our [ __ ] right but the good ones
you can't get no they're super hard to
come by
yeah
we need more screeners otherwise we
would have been able to watch Kardashian
right recap it right and I think like a
bunch of non-influential losers get the
Kardashian screeners and I just opened
my Kardashians on Hulu PR box I made
like a really cute video
um and I'd very much appreciate the
screener honestly if you want us to
recap it on Thursdays we're gonna need
the screeners or we'll just recap it on
Fridays and we you like the the Recaps
can be irrelevant that's on you Hulu
and like maybe if we don't recap it on
Friday then it waits till Monday and
then like by then everyone's moved on
yeah right like we're busy like sorry
we're so famous not famous enough to get
screeners but okay
I'm very appreciative of the pr box it
was very cool no I'm obsessed with that
818 hat I made such a funny video I'm
gonna post it on my reels the 818 hat is
so cool it actually matches my outfit
today exactly and I wanted to kind of
maybe wear it on the show but I thought
with the headphones it might be it might
also we in the pr box was the Beats by
Kim which I'm just grateful for
was that was so beyond General so beyond
generous because I want to talk about
something
I want to talk about airpods
okay so I have the OG air pods like my
first pair I ever bought and about two
years ago they started to crack out on
me and I wasn't giving up I'm like oh
you want to wait 30 you want to last 10
minutes with battery bet oh [ __ ] it I'm
gonna use you until I can't use you no
more mostly because I have we used to
sell like OG toasters well now we used
to sell decals for airpods so like my
airpods are tricked out in morning toe
stickers it's so cool and I wasn't
willing to give that up
it got to a point recently where like I
could not
use those as my headphones anymore like
they really they're they're broken
so then I was like you know I'm gonna
get airpods Max
and I was really excited until I went on
the website and I saw their 600 like I'm
sorry that's insane for a pair of
headphones like that's beyond the ones
that cover your ears yeah they're cool
they're stylish
um they're out of control I'm not
spending 600 like I'm just not so it's
like all right let me just get new
airpods and I was like I'm obviously
gonna get the most up-to-date airpods
like because my old ones obviously are
not cutting it so I got the third
generation and I don't know who needs to
hear this kind of today the theme of
today's episode is just like warnings
messages people need to hear you do not
need to get cautionary yeah you do not
need to get the new airpods they are the
most literal piece of [ __ ] product first
of all they're tiny good luck staying in
your ear I literally what's this one yes
yeah good luck staying in your ear
they're [ __ ] tiny they fall out
unless I have like big gaping ears which
I don't think that I do second of all
they're like they show up with these
factory settings and I have no [ __ ]
idea how to turn them off I'm just
listening to music and then Siri will
come on text from Jackie ashray hey
Claude how you doing like shut up [ __ ]
like shut up I don't know how the [ __ ]
to turn it off it's so annoying
do not get the third generation airpods
Max you can buy a brand new version of
the old ones I just thought it was like
silly to spend money on like the old
version no old version perfect
I just I think different occasions call
for different headphones there's no one
perfect headphone I do think airpods are
good in like casual settings if you're
walking in the street like you don't
want something that covers your ears you
need to be able to hear alert I don't
even want noise canceling you can turn
that off in settings
um you need to be aware 100 so I would
say for like casual taking like calls or
whatever face timing with headphones
airpods are fine we don't use them for
this show we don't use Bluetooth
headphones because we need the
connection to be so hard so we use wired
headphones I'm not crazy about the ones
that I wear they hurt my head a little
bit yes I think I'm gonna get a pair of
bows for this situation
but then I also need headphones for
working out and I need those to be tight
and right and loud as [ __ ] and I think
actually these Kim headphones I'm gonna
try those next yeah no like airpods just
had to go and like [ __ ] around and now
they found out because everyone hates
everyone I know like ah I know I'm gonna
I'm gonna get feedback everyone agrees
with me like I just know it because [ __ ]
Apple
yeah well that's that's something else
that's something else also [ __ ] Apple so
we sit here with all of our Apple
products 100 but like that's what
happens when you own the market and like
you have a monopoly and like you make
the best products but like the way that
they have to change the Chargers for all
their computers iPads phones like every
couple of years just so we all have to
buy new Chargers making our old Chargers
obsolete like that is so [ __ ] up and
that is actually like Financial abuse
honestly I really believe that no and
it's like you really need that money so
badly you're valued at a trillion
dollars you're really so desperate right
like as opposed to engendering Goodwill
right why aren't you what about goodness
why not engendering Goodwill
why not like making me love your company
instead of begrudgingly using right and
like rolling my eyes every time I walk
past a store
yeah I have like three Chargers here
they're all for different things they
all look different and my charge is not
charging on the iPad because it's got
used to your iPad instead of mine and
that girl was [ __ ] right I charging
my iPad and it's all your fault that
girl was [ __ ] right I hope you're
happy because I told you that girl was
on to something it is right sometimes
the charger does get you yeah instead of
mine and it all of a sudden doesn't work
because Apple Chargers are literally
fraudulent like I'm ready for the
documentary I'm ready for the untold
story of Apple Chargers
yeah I hope you're happy
Claude San Diego Chargers greater than
Apple Chargers so [ __ ] true so
[ __ ] true go charge yours
go churches oh actually I got some
feedback from our football discussion
yesterday which was riddled with
inconsistencies
um no us never Sports
couldn't be me but the 49ers
um which I've obviously like put my
entire you know life behind their
quarterback suffered a cur that a career
a season-ending injury he like broke his
ankle they've still got Jimmy Garoppolo
who's extremely hot like Kyle Jews check
like 49ers have all the hot players
I think that sometimes like when you
lose your big player this happens
sometimes like the person who comes off
the bench one is so grateful yeah for
the opportunity and they're gonna put
their heart and soul into it and like
the team sort of rallies around them and
it's kind of like an Underdog Story I
don't think it's
it's end person yeah it gives them a
ruach
it does a Spirit what team does Russell
Wilson play on he's also like one of the
hot ones I think the Seahawks he signed
like the most lucrative contract in NFL
history and honestly I'm just happy for
Sierra
except I saw you know what's so funny to
me about cancel culture not that I'm
like advocating for anyone to be
canceled I'm not I just feel like it's
so I think you're advocating for it for
consistency and so not nuanced and like
they just decide who's gonna get like
the Wrath and who's not and so Sierra
launched a skincare line or maybe a
beauty line I don't remember and she's
making all this content with all these
tick talkers and she made a tick tock
with this girl that I love Monet
um and they did it to the Sierra song
this beat is automatic and it's hypnotic
Funky Fresh So blank since it's so
arsler
so re since I started
um and not only did they use goodies
make boys jump on it no I can't control
my stuff and yes my stuff but yes I
farted
um so she made a tick tock with that
song
they could have used any 10 seconds of
the song they used the one with the
arsler and they're mouthing the words
and then they just like don't mouth to
the r part which I just think is so
[ __ ] weird like not only is that not
a word we use no one really acknowledges
how it's like put in that song and let's
get it started
you're gonna use that song to promote
your line and you're going to use that
part of the song like literally nobody
asked you like you could use any other
part of the song I just thought that was
so weird like where's the energy you
know not that I'm in any way advocating
I [ __ ] love Sierra she's a true
National Treasure and I'm obsessed with
her relationship with Russell Wilson I
just feel like the weird thing about
cancel culture is like it's not an equal
playing field you know
yeah so it's it's mixed messaging so
it's like okay we could listen to songs
with the r word but not the SP Stars
right right
and like if somebody had old tweets with
the r word which shout out I definitely
did uh like the energy for me and like
I'm a z-lister like Sierra's like an
alien you know what I mean like yeah
cancel culture like the levels make no
sense like why some people get so much
backlash some people get no backlash
some people don't even get like an
article written about it you know yeah
that's so true like and I'm grown enough
to acknowledge like in high school I use
that word all the time everyone I know
did it was like this is so like everyone
did now we're all adults who know it's
like not okay
mm-hmm but like where's the energy and I
can't stress enough how not
I'm not advocating for more cancel
culture I'm advocating if we're gonna
live in cancel culture which we are like
everyone's like I hate cancer culture
but they all participate in it like we
live in the cancel culture so I want
equal energy cultures the culture is
canceled I want equal energy for equal
uh crimes and I also want like if you're
an a-lister you deserve more backlash
than a b-lister like I'm sorry it has to
be tiered
agreed
agreed so I'm against cancer culture but
let's acknowledge a fact that like sorry
we actually we do we live in a society
where everyone gets canceled for things
they said mistakes they've made things
they said in the past old tweets that is
the world we live in so I want Equal
justice
and like sometimes people are are like
you know the pendulum is swinging oh
please people have been saying that for
five years
it's over you know it's not and then
I'll see someone get canceled for and
I'm like this is a joke right
right and like this is the smallest
potatoes I've seen yet right no and like
when I always think about like our old
cancellation how like it was probably
like the level of an A-list celebrity
when back then we were true [ __ ]
irrelevant uglies like the way there was
so much energy for us when like we were
actual nobodies it did make us into
somebody's and like that's the small
part I'm grateful for like I think this
show is what it is because like a lot of
people found out about us from our
cancellation and they were like oh well
this is crazy but the girl these are
kind of funny you know
so I just think like that was so crazy
and then I see like I feel like I know
this is gonna sound so crazy I've been
like and maybe maybe my perception of it
is is skewed because it happened to me
and it felt like so much press but I do
believe that is what happened I felt
like we got more backlash and bad
articles written about us than literally
like Ansel Elgort
yeah like is that crazy to say
no I don't think so so I just feel like
with cancel culture I've acknowledged
that that's a culture we live in and I'm
I'm gonna start like I'm gonna petition
like I want more consistency more
equality more more appropriate amounts
of backlash to certain situations
no and I love Sierra this is Sierra just
is the launching pad for this
conversation because honestly people
come for Sierra like I will defend her
to the death like back then like you
could make a song like that you could
no the song the song stops and like
literally it went through record labels
press like nobody thought it was there
was anything wrong with that because
back in the day like nobody thought
there was anything wrong with using that
word
right and like if we're gonna go after
that song for that word we have to start
with let's get it right the Black Eyed
Peas in the title that one's in the
title that one's in the title so that
one would be like the bigger yeah yeah
um no what I find interesting about like
the media and like the inequal
cancellation and whatnot it's like I
could do anything in this world and I
will never get pressed for like anything
good we can do right ever
if I say one thing wrong it's a buzzfeed
article everyone's interested yeah and
the bad thing I said right right so it's
like we aren't actually not famous
enough to Garner press unless unless we
say something mildly unpopular which we
have many times and all of a sudden like
we're the biggest stars right and no
like I could literally genuinely take a
bullet for someone and no one would
cover the Press no no we could do like
we do really cool things like with our
platform with our podcast like even like
when news comes out our personal life
and nothing no no no no no no no but the
second I you know maybe offend a pit
bull it's over
I just think it's interesting and I
agree like there's no sense in being
anti-cancel culture anymore because like
you lost so now that we live in cancel
culture now that we live in cancel
culture I've accepted it but I'm going
to advocate for more equitable
distribution of the assets
yeah that's it
that's it that's it and I'm so glad we
had this conversation because it's
critical culture is extremely nuanced
every situation is so different and I
feel like the energy doesn't match for
for some situations versus others
I would actually say it's more nuanced
and it should be more yes and it is
right right right and like whatever I
read about in my book girl with no
job.com book also I'll see you guys in
Long Island this weekend Saturday I feel
like this part's gonna get clipped out
and like passed around so I'm let's like
promote everything yeah um okay so I am
a touring comedian I have a show I only
have like eight shows left this one is
in Long Island New York in Huntington
Saturday seven o'clock it's gonna be
super fun there are very few tickets
left my last show in New York and then
I'm hitting uh Pittsburgh Alabama
Nashville all those shows are sold out
honestly this one in New York has like
50 tickets left and that's the only one
so if you're missing out on the funny
show of your life that's on you
so
yeah that was really everything I wanted
to talk about before we started what
about you
I think I'm good as well I finished my
drug and alcohol abuse scores
and and I'm feeling they let you break
it up you don't have to do it all in
four hours
yes no they you can log out come back in
you're you're still there it actually
wound up me taking me like four hours
and 45 minutes not bad
um I'm feeling really passionate about
these good good
so
like you have to think about it like I
feel like [ __ ] like that like everyone
knows drinking and driving is wrong but
then like you you become a mom and you
realize like Harry's going to be driving
one day and you want everyone on the
road to be on their best [ __ ]
Behavior
yeah they better yeah
I'm literally like when Harry gets his
first car like I will wrap my body
around it and be like a force field of
protection like that's how I would lay
my life out on the line for him but at
the rate I'm going he's gonna get his
before yeah 100 I'm I'm working towards
I'm working towards my goals but they're
just like not but they're just so hard
they're so hard like
it's crazy I mean even in the in the
course it was like all these reasons you
could get your permit or license
suspended it's like if you missed 15
days of school unexcused absences like
and I'm like wait by the way first of
all I didn't know that that was a thing
that's so interesting too at least in
Florida two not you taking your courses
your course with the 16 year olds
no and it's like and if you're still 14
you just need a parent to sign off I'm
like if I'm still 14 I'm literally
turning 40.
yeah that's crazy no I'm turning 30 in
November you guys so
um and Lou and get in lieu of gifts just
follow me in lieu of gifts just cancel
Sierra no I'm kidding
I'm totally kidding I cannot stress how
I'm not advocating for that like she's
one of the few celebrities I literally
took a bullet for I love her and I love
her husband and I love their wedding it
was literally the most stunning thing
ever
okay now let's jump in
you maybe could stand to know um before
you wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
today's episode is brought to you by
thumba
let me build
introducing the bed by thuma handcrafted
from eco-friendly high quality upcycled
wood you'll find beautiful unique
variations in the natural grain so if
you are in the process of refreshing
your bedroom either you're moving you're
just ready for you know a reset now is
the perfect time to elevate the most
important room in your home with thuma
so it is the perfect platform bed and it
just got better you can now customize
the bed by thuma by choosing between the
original pillow board the new solid wood
headboard the fabric pillow board adds a
softness and a color to your space while
the headboard offers solid Sleek support
it attaches directly to the bed by using
Japanese joinery no tools are required
to set up the bed by thuma
um you can buy it with the bed or choose
it as an upgrade it's made for how you
live so if you have ever had the great
Misfortune of setting up Furniture you
know it's actual hell on Earth like
there is a special place in hell for
people who design that kind of stuff the
bed by Thurlow will take you five
minutes no tools are required it comes
in three easy to maneuver boxes it is
literally genius it's genius it's saving
marriages all over the country and for
that we're extremely grateful they also
offer obviously the bed but they have
other Essentials that offer that elevate
bedtime so the mattress the nightstand
the side table they're all perfectly
complimenting to the bed and they're
stunning easy to set up worry for a
hassle-free create the feeling of
checking into your favorite boutique
hotel suite but at home with the bed by
thuma now go to thuma.co toast to
receive a 25 credit towards your
purchase of the bad plus free shipping
in the continental US go to thuma.co
toast that's t-h-u-m-a dot c o slash
toast for 25 credit today's episode is
also brought to you by Samsung com if
you're a small business owner you know
how important it is to be ready for the
insane holiday season and if you haven't
started preparing for the chaos of the
holiday mailing and shipping you're
already falling behind luckilystamps.com
is everything you need to make your life
a whole lot easier it's the 24 7 post
office that you can access from anywhere
no lines no traffic no hassle stamps.com
is your One-Stop shop for all your
shopping and mailing needs for more than
20 years stamps.com has been an
indispensable resource for over a
million businesses you can get access to
USPS UPS Service rates
everything that you need to run your
business right from your computer and
with inflation On The Rise every dollar
counts protect your margins with major
discounts on the USPS and UPS shipping
rates you can get up to 86 off and you
don't have to leave your house
heaven I'm in heaven get ahead of the
holiday chaos this year and get started
with stamps.com today sign up with promo
code toast for a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a free digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com Click the microphone at
the top of the home page and enter code
toast
okay thank you Claudia you're welcome
our first story though we did not watch
the Kardashians last night Khloe
Kardashian has shared a first look into
her son's birth as she puts her Tristan
Thompson trauma behind her Chloe is
focusing on better days ahead and with
the new little one by her side in last
night's season two premiere of the
Kardashians she gave fans the first look
from inside the birth of her son who
arrived months after her ex Tristan's
paternity Scandal first surfaced the
emotional moment was captured on camera
by Kim who was able to join her in uh
the hospital for her surrogates delivery
on July 20. that makes me like oh yeah
so emo that Kim was there
I know well they couldn't have everyone
there because of covid stuff so Kim was
there then they facetimed true and Chris
and was Tristan there
Chloe let Tristan come after
Kim was there it's like all of his
Affairs are just like always timed up
with like
the third trimester the birth yeah and
she's like always having to be the
bigger person and it's really [ __ ]
annoying for her
yeah well so she said in the episode
ever since December it's been this Dark
Cloud looming over me every single day
I've been feeling depressed and sad and
now that my son is here I get to move on
and I get to enjoy it's almost like I
get to close that chapter and be done
with this trauma and put it behind me
she continued as a video montage of her
and Kim holding the baby flashed across
the screen she said now I finally get to
start the healing process now I get to
start enjoying my life with two kids in
it and figuring this out this is gonna
be day one and this is going to be the
start of something positive and happy
and beautiful oh my God I'm like so emo
over the fact that like it was her and
Kim like
because that's literally that line from
friends like boyfriends and girlfriends
will come and go but this is for life
like family is for Life family is always
there for you and even though like your
husband like is supposed to be your
family
um he was never her husband so I just
I'm like really happy for Chloe that she
has that support system because she's
that support for all of her sisters like
she's always that one showing up for
everyone supporting like putting her
needs on the back end and I love that
she chose Kim I'm like loving how close
they are recently and I feel like
Kardashians on Hulu really highlighted
how like it used to be like Chloe and
Courtney like always leaving Kim out and
now I feel like Chloe and Kim are like
in just like similar places in their
life and they're really connecting and I
love how close they are
yeah it is so sweet and I feel like that
was our sort of take
when everything came out about Chloe and
the surrogate in like in light of
Tristan's everything like now that she
has this baby oh all that matters like
Tristan honestly he can go for 100 and
she'll always be so respectful in the
bigger person and like couldn't be me
then I think much Kinder than most
people would be couldn't be couldn't but
this is what matters and
this episode like they focused on the
whole journey like I think it you know
probably starts in December and ends in
July you end with the birth they didn't
tell us what the name was but it will
start with a t they said okay so our
guess of RJ Jr
is not correct
okay but did we guess any T names thuma
or it could be
I mean if she was in a good place with
Tristan he could be TJ right but
honestly she wouldn't
desecrate the beauty of birth by naming
someone after Tristan which just sucks
because TJ's such a cute name
so cute um okay but like I never would
have been able to guess true because up
until true Thompson true was not a
[ __ ] name now it is yeah so it could
be tree oh
wait it's a boy sorry true and tree are
also too similar and there's only one
famous tree and her daughters so
um that's not gonna work but let me
think
let's Google T names they did this on
the show last night yeah but it wouldn't
come up if it's anything like true
yeah oh Theo's the name of the other one
who oh [ __ ] Charlie Nichols wow the fact
that she has a teen name too is like her
fall
even though like she has every right to
yeah Thomas Thiago
Tyler Tucker Tatum Taylor I feel like
it's just gonna be like a new name like
time no like
yeah tired Tyson
Tyson I actually like guys Tobias yes
okay
Titus Andromeda there's only that's a
good name it is but there's really only
one Titus and it's Titus andromedan the
grenada's character in television
history
even though I think often about how like
Titus andromedan is literally me like
I'm obsessed
um and Titus Burgess who's a character
who plays him like is like low-key rude
like have you ever seen him on watch
Happens Live it's like my favorite thing
to talk about I feel like I talk about
it all the time
uh yes and yes he was so rude and I also
met him one time when I was an intern
and he was also so rude
yeah he's not I asked him if we could
like reference and like I was like my
job was to like meet the celebrity and
like make them take a picture and my I
was like can you do Pinot Noir like a
bit from Kimmy Schmidt and he was like
no and I felt so stupid and ugly and bad
like I was just I was literally 17. I
was so nervous I was obsessed with Titus
and I was like okay like hi I'm Claudia
I'm like the social manager like can we
just get some photos maybe like a video
of you doing Pinot Noir and he was like
no
I was like okay I'll just die thanks
yeah he's not the type that loves the
thing that made him famous and that just
couldn't be and like he was mean to me
like a lowly intern and then he was also
like [ __ ] rude to Andy on watch
Happens live because like Andy didn't
know like every single thing about the
play he was currently in
which it's definitely annoying when
you're like doing press and the person
like hasn't read your book or like
clearly didn't finish it because they
asked you a question that's like in the
book or in the play but Andy's question
was like not that
crazy like and it set him off he was so
rude that's like one of my favorite
clips to watch
foreign
great
uh our next story is a little more
Kardashian news because Kanye is sitting
down with ABC's Lindsey Davis for an
interview and that whole thing airs
tonight on ABC at 8 30 but a preview was
shown on Good Morning America this
morning where he's talking about
fatherhood apologizing to Kim I'm
talking about you know father's rights
um he said what are father's rights
that he wanted to say and how his kids
are being raised just as much as Kim
like that he's not just a sperm donor
like he should be able to say like where
they go to school I agree with that but
um why is he talking about it on ABC
News talk about it with Kim
yeah well I think one Kim gets to do her
long-form thoughts on the show but she
doesn't really talk about it
no she does like it takes months until
we really hear from her whenever he's
having an outburst but then like she
sits down on Kardashian Zulu and talks
about it
you know like I guess I don't know why I
don't really know why he went to GMA or
whatever but I guess it's
I don't know if it's any better or worse
than doing it on Instagram as he
normally does but it definitely seems
like it's more thoughtful right but I
also talking about like being I also
think about GMA being on ABC right ABC
is a part of the Hulu family
the Kardashians had to have gotten a
heads up about this or like I feel like
they could have
like they could have stopped it
yeah but I so far from what I've seen
like there's nothing nefarious nefarious
disrespectful or anything like he's
always crediting Kim as a mom he just
like wants more say he said he'd had to
fight for a voice in his kids upbringing
which had left him feeling hurt he said
I'm their dad it has to be co-parenting
it's not only up to the woman like men
have a choice also men's voices matter
and then he showed a video of north at
donda Academy
um having a great time dancing to music
right it's like he wants to stay in his
kids as education not like should we go
to this private school or this private
school he wants the kids to go to his
own school like it's not a balanced
conversation
well see it is the difference between
this private school and this private
school and I agree with him I think and
it's so nice that like he wants to be so
involved but then you think of someone
like Tristan and like he doesn't deserve
equal sense in what Chloe's doing so I
think it's a case-by-case situation well
actually like
he does deserve equal say like he's no I
don't think so he's the dad like he does
I know but like maybe it's just like as
a mama bear now
no really like
like I think yes okay if the person is a
murderer or like a sex offender like
okay great yeah you obviously like don't
get to say but like cheating is terrible
it's terrible it's terrible it's not you
know but like you're not a mature adult
you don't put your family first you
don't think about your kids and your and
your lady love before you think about
your penis like I'm not leading you with
the big decisions and if we disagree on
something like I'm getting my way well I
think just in general in hetero
relationships like if we're disagreeing
on something the mom wins like
that I agree with like you can have your
opinion but at the end of the day if
we're not gonna come to a compromise I
win like moms win I think that that's
fair no and like and then he lied about
knowing that he had a kid coming on the
way he has Chloe going forward with
surrogacy when he knows that he has a
kid coming like that's not a person I
would leave big decisions to and you
don't get as much say no not in this
moment but I do think this is the
official end for Chloe and Tristan and
like years from now when she's in a
relationship he's in a relationship he's
doing whatever he wants
um and there are big decisions about
like where's true going to go to college
like I think they both have equal say
not in this moment obviously but when
the dust has settled
you don't yeah like you don't not get a
say in your child's life forever because
you were a dick
any say and you have he obviously will
see them and whatnot but like
the mother is like the head the mother
is the heavy I completely agree
but I think other situations are
different yeah it's like cancel culture
everything is nuanced we have to judge
it on a case-by-case basis
right and so I think for Kanye who wants
to be so involved and I think he is a
good dad yeah he's not you know putting
all the family drama on blast Instagram
um
and he wants like he's very involved and
interested and so it's just a balancing
act but like yeah I I hate when stuff
like this is done publicly like this is
really truly none of our business like
we shouldn't know that Kim and Kanye are
arguing about which school to send their
kids to like it's so personal
but honestly this conversation feels
less personal than everything I came
before of course I'm just really curious
like I always just associate Kanye doing
press with Kanye not doing well
he this like this is what he said in
then this is just a clip but so far it
really seems like he's fine he said this
is the mother of my children and I
apologize for any stress that I've
caused even in my frustration because
God calls me to be stronger I need this
person to be less stressed and of the
best sound mind as calm as possible be
able to raise those children at the end
of the day
like and and he's um he said he has a
new respect for Kim and that he's always
wanted to be calm oh okay and like he's
the one who's like making her right
right right and he's sorry oh that's
sweet that's actually really sweet
I need to watch the interview before I
really like say anything else
also speaking of Kanye like he's been in
the news for this Gap in India stuff
um he's no longer doing collabs with
either of them
and he's posting everyone's leadership
honestly like when Kanye goes like so
Random Deep dive like posting all these
businessmen like it does I know I sound
[ __ ] crazy it does make me feel like
one day like he might like reference our
close on Sunday like partnership with
him like
what because like he's obviously like he
knows about what goes on in his business
he doesn't just design like he gets to
know like the fact that like someone
from Yeezy had reached out to us and
gave us an unreleased kindness that was
sanctioned by Conde like I know I sound
crazy I just feel like one day he'll
like posts the clip you know
do you know what I mean
and just is that delusional comes no I
never I've literally never thought about
it because when he's like referencing
like the lawyers who did the deal and
this one guy who works at Gap corporate
like he's not just like this type of
artist who does Partnerships and does it
like he knows everything that goes on in
his business like that's my takeaway
when he's posting these random people's
[ __ ] linkedins like that's my
takeaway so the fact that we had like an
official communication with you know a
Yeezy employee who obviously had gotten
approval from Kanye to give us his
unreleased song to sing on our podcast
years ago it makes me think like in some
way like we could come back on his radar
another time like when he's on an
Instagram spiral and like blowing people
up
yeah and it's I think it would only be
like if we're saying like something
completely supportive or completely
detracted right and so that leads me to
say like I think the kids should be
going to donda Academy
and I think they should live in Chicago
it looks like great I'm actually
thinking of sending my kids to donde
Academy they have a Jewish program
that's really it's on par with Chabad
you know the done Academy stuff like I
think it's yeah for sure
yeah we'll have to do a tour 100
are you ready for our next story
speaking of press Olivia Wilde is making
the rounds and talking about some of it
she was on The Late Show with Stephen
Colbert let me guess let me guess her
answer
I just don't think this would be a
conversation would be having if I
weren't a woman
amongst other things yes she doubled
down on her claim that she fired Shia
LaBeouf from don't worry darling now
alleging he gave her an ultimatum with
flaw Miss flow she said quote we had to
replace Shia he's a fantastic actor but
it wasn't gonna work when he gave me the
ultimatum of you know or of or when he
gave me the ultimatum of you know him or
Miss Florence I chose did she say Miss
Florence no oh I did I was just about to
say I can't say Florence without
misspell but I realize in this context
it's not appropriate it's important for
me to get it right in response to Shai's
claim that Olivia had begged him to stay
on the project she clarified quote that
was feel that was him feeling he was
stepping away and me feeling like we
were moving on without him she said
early on in the process of making the
film as the Director I tried to mediate
a situation between people to try and
see if they could work together happily
once it became clear that it was not
attainable working relationship I was
given an ultimatum I chose my actress
which I'm very happy I did also in this
interview she's going hard for Florence
she said at the time it was I bum that
we weren't able to make it work yes did
information come about him come to light
later that made me confident we made the
right choice yes
she said
um about Florence she's Sensational in
this film and it is about her being
brave enough to listen to the brave
people who come before her who everyone
else has ignored and trust her Instinct
she said Florence is a good is as good a
dramatic work as she is as at action I
have nothing but respect for Florence's
Talent she's fantastic she's on the set
of her movie Dune part two right now
there's nothing cooler than a busy
actress I have nothing against her for
any reason no so uh Margo our sister had
actually seen the movie I spoke to her
about it last night she said it
literally flow like flows the whole
movie it's like not even Harry it's Flo
um and that she was marvelous like
really incredible so I think you know
what regardless of their relationship
like press wise like she has to praise
flow
yeah and it's like why should she have
anything against low other than the fact
that Flo kind of blew up her spot but if
she were mad at flow about that it would
also be kind of like saying yeah what
she said is true I think taking the high
road in real in the relation to her beef
with Florence is really like her only
yeah especially because Florence clearly
did such a great job in the movie now
the stuff with Shia I could actually see
how some of it was taken out of context
I think that like she's been a little
bit villainized in the sense that I
think that that
um obviously when she was begging him to
come back to the movie that wasn't the
last thing that happened they must have
been trying to make it work and then
after that video he gave her an
ultimatum and she chose Florence but I
think the reason why it's murky is
because she acted like she fired him
based on allegations yeah because it
wasn't a safe no she like used a
movement
to like make herself a hero however I do
think like I can see a world in which
your director working with famous
celebrities with big Egos and you like
let them down in in certain like kind of
manipulative ways to let them think that
they walked away even though like behind
the scenes I actually can totally see
how like she was happy to let Shia think
that he was the one
making the decision like giving him that
power just to keep like actors egos in
check even though like this was some
sort of calculated plan to get rid of
him in a peaceful way
I just think they're actually like both
not lying they're just like not telling
the whole story like she did fire him if
he gave her an ultimatum but shy is
saying like you also you wanted me to be
in it but I couldn't make it work right
and I think that was actually probably
an intentional thing that Olivia did
like let him think this is his decision
even though like we want to get rid of
him
like yeah I just think that there's more
stuff that happened after that video but
the video of indicate Chaya because it's
like no she wanted me to be in it at
still at a certain point that video was
really bad like really bad but I think
it might be a little frustrating for
because there's
there was more than I wanted
um
and now she's like doing the Press tour
she was on Kelly where her conversation
was a bit lighter where she pretty much
was like because Kelly was like I'm not
gonna ask you about it because I think
Kelly you know knows what it's like to
be misunderstood and in the press and
everything and Olivia just sort of
skirts around it and saying you know
there's people who are living without
water and like that's more important oh
my God I mean there are people who are
living without water and we all need to
like really be helpful and talk about
that but that's neither here nor there
yeah no like make a movie about it use
your platform you have a platform
got him but this is the this is the
movie that you made so we're talking
about this right and you're actually
doing press for this particular movie
that's why we are talking about it and
not the Water Crisis
but if the movie is about the Water
Crisis of course we would and maybe you
should have thought of that before you
made a movie not about the Water Crisis
it's just oh and of course she said
um to Stephen Colbert quote I think
what's funny is like I don't feel like
my male director colleagues are
answering questions about their cast
I hate that [ __ ] because first of all no
she's right we're not because I've never
seen a video of a male director uh that
made them look like a big [ __ ] liar
like if there was just you know if there
was a video of James Cameron going
around like lying to Kate Winslet about
Leonardo DiCaprio you bet your ass would
be talking about it every single day on
the show but there's not so you're a
woman yes but you're also a woman who
found herself in a situation that I have
not seen from another male director and
I feel like there's actually a lot of
like a decent amount of drama with male
directors like that that guy Jane
Michael Bay I mean that James Gunner or
whatever like James got and yeah
guardians Guardians of the Galaxy which
I don't know enough about the situation
but I remember like everyone was talking
about the fact like all these actors
penned a note on his behalf even though
I think he like might be a sex offender
or something like there was weird [ __ ]
so I feel like there's actually a decent
amount of drama with directors and by
the way especially when uh it's a
director getting involved with uh that
anyone on the film like Kristen Stewart
you know why that we were talking on
that direction also most directors
aren't famous she is a actress celebrity
first a director second maybe that won't
be the case in a few years no like most
directors aren't going on Stephen
Colbert most directors are [ __ ]
irrelevant I wouldn't know them on the
street if they took a dump on my chest
like
yeah I wouldn't that's a really good
point that's actually she's a celebrity
first and that's why we're talking about
it not because she's a woman I hate that
[ __ ]
yeah I agree you're famous like
literally Jason Sudeikis Harry Styles
like there's a lot going on
no and she's a front-facing person right
like she's beautiful most directors are
B most directors are B2B she's B to C
yep therefore we are talking about it
it's in the Press
okay next up are you ready for our next
story if it's next story that's brought
to you by Noom Noom wait
yeah when we decide to lose weight it's
usually not just about the number on the
scale whatever your reason is for
wanting to make a change new weight is
ready to help there's psychology-based
approach empowers you with the knowledge
and support to build lasting results
with their psychology first approach
NuMe weight empowers you to build more
sustainable habits and behaviors because
you guys know like crash diets like
don't work unless you're like actually
like implementing real changes into your
everyday life a lifestyle which is
psychological it's not anything that's
outside of your brain like it's the
rewiring of your brain that's why new
weight is really effective to date new
weight has helped more than 3.6 million
people lose the weight every journey is
different so your daily lessons are
going to be personalized to you as well
as your goals the program is based on
scientific principles like cognitive
behavioral therapy CBT to help you
understand your relationship with food I
feel like that was a huge
kind of um
shock to me it's like okay well diet and
exercise diet and exercise and then I'll
go back to the way I used to be and it's
like no Noom actually really taught me
like you have to completely rewire the
way your brain works because like the
way you eat it's not like a stomach
thing it's a brain thing
um and so the cognitive behavioral
therapy has been like super helpful I
also really like nooms food database
because if you want to track what you
eat like all these different apps like
they stink like you're literally just
making stuff up they never actually have
what you're eating they have one of the
most accurate food databases on Noom so
if you're looking for like a really
effective end
efficient way to track what you're
eating and just like your intake the new
food tracker is fabulous stay focused on
what's important to you with nooms new
weights psychology-based approach sign
up for your trial today at noom.com
toast that's n o o m.com slash toast to
sign up for your trial today
great I'm so glad that we have a new mad
because I'm back on my new Grind and
it's so it's so helpful when you're
trying to make a lifestyle change and
like you can look back and be like oh I
didn't get the results I wanted this
week why what was I doing where do I
need to edit
okay our next story is actually um some
cancel culture news let me finish
reading it before you comment because
there's been an update Tiffany haddish
claims she lost all of her jobs amid the
child molestation lawsuit Tiffany
haddish claims she quote lost everything
as a result of the now dismissed
allegations of child molestation and
grooming made against turn fellow comic
Ari Spears she told TMZ all my gigs gone
everything gone I don't have no job bro
according to IMDb she has two products
in post-production but none that she's
currently filming are listed as in
pre-production she also has no upcoming
tour dates for her Comedy Tour per
Ticketmaster haddish and Spears were
accused of grooming and molesting a
brother and sister when they were 14 and
7 years old respectfully in a lawsuit
filed earlier this month
the alleged victims claim that she
coerced them into participating in
explicit comedy skits
um the suit the siblings who made the
accusations dismissed the lawsuit this
week they said quote my family and I
have known Tiffany haddish for many
years and we now know that she would
never harm me or my brother or help
anyone else do anything that could harm
us she told TMZ on Tuesday on behalf of
herself and her brother we wish Tiffany
the best and are glad that we can put
this all behind us what
yeah oh but wait
but those videos were made like
yeah I don't I really am so confused it
sounds like seriously someone's holding
a gun to their head like say that right
I know and I don't want to like accuse
me one of anything but like I'm so
confused because I felt so sick sick
reading the story like genuinely
horrified for the case to be dismissed
and for the woman to say like never mind
never harm us
maybe they like chatted offline and came
to an understanding right because at the
end of the day
this is hearsay obviously like you're
supposed to you know believe the victim
but and that can lead people to be
doubtful like there's no like full proof
but those videos like you can watch it
it's disgusting and I wouldn't I
wouldn't and I know people have but like
there is video evidence of extremely
inappropriate content being made
yeah
so maybe it all happened but
in a different way
obviously
yeah because part of me is like well if
they're you know saying it didn't happen
and the case is dismissed and like
that's not right that Tiffany haddish is
you know
of course but then I think about how
those videos still were made by Tiffany
haddish
but
these statements they don't say that it
never happened it's just like she's just
singing a different tune now and I just
feel like maybe they have like an
arrangement spoken and figured something
out she said my family and I have known
Tiffany excuse me ads
she said that
no
if the ads just are coming in front of
my quote okay my family and I have known
Tiffany haddish for many years and we
now know that she would never harm me or
my brother or help anyone else do
anything that could harm us we wish
Tiffany the best and are glad that we
can put this all behind us well the
interesting thing is that they're saying
Tiffany
not Arya Spears
yeah Ari Spears for his part slam the
claims and called them extortion well
the thing about being a comedian is that
like your career is what you make it in
the sense that like you know Louis CK
was widely canceled and he's still one
of the most popular comedians he doesn't
do anything mainstream he doesn't go on
the late night shows he doesn't have a
special on Netflix he tours all around
the country he does huge venues he sells
his specials directly to his listeners
as a comedian like you can have a very
prosperous career that's why you know
people who do stand up and become really
really famous they never stop doing
stand-up because the day that all those
movies and everything stops you can
always go back to making a hundred grand
a night selling out a stadium
yeah so well Stadium no no sorry you
make 100 Grand a night like selling out
like like a big ass theater like us like
six to ten thousand person which like
the Dolby Radio City Madison Square
Garden like that's the type of venue so
that's what's interesting about being a
comedian is like as a comedian you can
truly and that's why I think it's kind
of a safe career for people to say
whatever they want because at the end of
the day like even when Chappelle was
like
so on the outs after Chappelle Show and
was considered like this radioactive he
was still one of the most successful
touring comedians because people don't
care oh you're not a Comedy Central
anymore I can buy a ticket to your show
like you don't need the industry
behind you or to have to necessarily
even approve you because you sell
tickets directly to your fans you sell
your comedy specials directly to your
fans patreon is a new wave of that like
all these comedians who aren't really
Hollywood are still some of the most
like successful comedians in terms of
touring sell out just as big of a venue
as like a Jerry Seinfeld
yeah Amy Schumer no and the money is
there too like Amy Schumer literally
sold at Madison Square Garden theater
and like so did my eye you know what I
mean
sure that's actually a really good
comparison something like so many of the
um like comedians who come from
podcasting digital world
are doing the same venues as an Amy
Schumer as well not there's there's but
then there's like another level of like
Chappelle Sebastian Maniscalco those are
the only Kevin Hart no I'm not talking
about them like I'm really talking about
like podcasting comedians who are like
they're not digitally native but have
like used the internet who are big on
patreon
give themselves a career do you read
times no it's on my list
oh he couldn't get a special at first
like filmed it himself sold it I think
it was back when like he printed um DVDs
I'm crying yeah
um
so yeah there is big money in that but
it's funny because I feel like there are
some comedians not the Chappelle's and
Sebastian those are like and Kevin Hart
those are like they have the industry
and they have the audience
but there are so many comedians that
just have these I know I I don't I don't
know who you're thinking of but like I'm
thinking of literally one person in
particular and it's like I don't think
this person has any actual fans but it's
like Netflix special put her on late
night it's like who how did who is this
person
I'm not gonna like dog fellow female
comedians I just find it interesting
yeah and so
and that's how I kind of feel about a
lot of SNL cast members not all of them
some of them are genuinely funny and
have audiences but the thing is about
SNL is like you actually don't need to
have like a huge fan base to do your job
well
you just need to be funny do good
Impressions be a good writer like
yeah
but it's not gonna make you a rockstar
comedian if you don't have like that
galvanized audience and you're not like
but I also just feel like those days are
like kind of over where like you're
becoming like a
Nationwide the biggest comedian after
doing SNL like I feel like Pete Davidson
was super rare because that hasn't
happened like since Keenan
yeah but I wouldn't even say he's like
the biggest no no no no but he's famous
like honestly Michael Che and and Colin
Jose they do stand up together they go
on tour they sell huge venues I that
just doesn't happen anymore they've been
on the show for 10 years
yeah so the thing is like when you get
canceled as a comedian it's not the same
as being canceled as an actor
you're canceled as an actor you're
[ __ ] because in order to be a
successful actor you need the industry
to approve you you need to be in the
green you need to be in movies you can't
just like go to a theater and do a
one-handed show so with a that's why
like so many people just like you would
think like why does Sherry Seinfeld
still do stand up
it's because like it's just built into
like the DNA of a comedian like never
give that up because like you could lose
everything and you just have to go back
that's how Chappelle built it all he got
so canceled Chappelle show was canceled
he was so irrelevant literally
excommunicated by Hollywood so we just
kept touring touring touring and then he
became so big at touring they couldn't
ignore him anymore
like and that's the beauty of being a
comedian what's happening with Louis CK
yeah
exactly just half the world he's like
right the other half he's like the best
right and he's making money hand over
fist
people just love him
so I am confused as hell about this
Tiffany but what I mean why I brought
that up is that she's going to be fine
there's no shows on Ticketmaster that's
not because Ticketmaster won't have her
go on tour
uh yeah Ticketmaster we'll sell your
tickets
but do you think at this point I mean
people love her like in movies and stuff
but can she sell tickets yeah
yeah I think she can
okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story someone else is selling
something who
Brad Pitt debuted his new skincare line
he credits his ex Gwyneth Paltrow for
getting him to wash his face okay every
time Gwyneth Paltrow and Brad Pitt even
remotely reference each other I fall so
head over heels into shipdom even though
there are a few couples I love on this
planet more than Gwyneth Paltrow and
Brett falchuk I think they have like a
really strong marriage and I'm really
happy for them but when she referenced
like that whole Harvey Weinstein with
him like they always just like maybe
like once every few years will reference
their relationship in such a positive
light
it makes me want to cry
I know it makes me want to cry that I
was alive
present for it I was alive but I was
right right I was four
Brad Pitt has entered the skincare chat
the actor and director announced his new
collection called lead domain Skin Care
in an interview with British Vogue and
opened up about his own skincare routine
and which one of his famous exes
influenced his brand and his Beauty
routine he said I love what gwyneth's
done with goop she is still a really
dear friend and she has built this
Empire she's always had that impressive
curator and it's been and it's been a
lovely creative outlet for her in fact
come to think about it she was probably
the first one to get me to wash even
wash my face twice a day maybe
Brad wanted to make it clear though that
despite this being his brand with she
created with the help of the parent
family of Vintners oh I feel like he is
not the face of the brand he is however
the driving force behind the BR the
products creation which use great braced
antioxidants I'm sorry from Chateau what
are you saying great okay it's the Skin
Care uses grape based antioxidants from
his Vineyard Vineyard Chateau oh my God
is that the loudest that's like a
contests a huge asset in his divorce
that like nobody wants to give it up
sorry what I'm trying to what I'm trying
to say is that he was using these grapes
on his face at his Vineyard and now he's
bottling it and selling it and he's just
like one person in the chain and I don't
know why you wouldn't be the face of
skincare when you're Brad Pitt this is
Brad right
um but he really believes in this stuff
he said he's got sent like so much stuff
over the years it's all crap and that if
this didn't work he wouldn't bother with
it but it's the real deal okay I'm like
really Beyond like shook that like we're
having this conversation like Brad Pitt
releasing a skincare line is so beneath
him like it's giving
like it's it's so weird
I'm not here for it I'm sorry do I
believe the grapes are great for your
skin yes do I believe it's better than
anything that's currently on the market
no I don't know why he's doing this it's
so bizarre and it makes me think he's
hard up for cash
I think maybe he said in an interview a
few months ago that like he's in
I don't want to I don't know if I'm
misquoting but kind of like the final
chapter of his life yes
and he's a actor and a director but like
those sorts of things like you need to
work to get paid and maybe he's just at
a point in his life where he's like I
want the checks to come in like I want
to build a business and not have to work
for Everything 100 right and if that was
the case I can't imagine that he would
land on skin care I feel like he would
invest in like a couple Like Liquor
businesses uh maybe like Tech I feel
like when you're that famous you get
opportunities to invest early in
companies that are no doubt gonna make
you money like that's how the rich get
richer like they get those opportunities
that nobody else gets I feel like he
probably could get a hundred businesses
wanting his money that are
75 gonna make it you know
you don't think like he sat down with
his team like why would he start like
from inception that's more work
well Brad what are you known for that's
more work than just writing a check he
has to come up with the name The
Branding the formulas like write a check
to Spritz society and we'll do the work
for you you know what I mean
but I think he's not someone who doesn't
want to work you just said he wants the
checks to come to him right but he I
think he wants to work smarter and I
don't think skin care is gonna be that
no it's it's surprising it makes me
think that this grape stuff must be
right out of Youth maybe Angelina was
using it too maybe we need to because
like that could be the only reason why
he's doing this because we absolutely
have to have this product on the market
right but it's giving like 4 a.m
infomercial
yeah
anyways do with that information what
you will I feel like you needed to know
it and we all need to chew it 100 but
what I really need to do is talk about
the Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
because the blow up of all blops we
finally kind of sort of got it last
night let's not at all we got absolutely
nothing we got the saddest party I've
ever seen it was giving basement hangout
in the eighth grade
yes and that's what every single party
on all real housewives have turned into
I think since covid but they obviously
don't care to step it up it's only the
women getting together in like a house
or a sad venue getting dressed to the
nines in a theme and being pathetic so
let's dive into the TV recap which is
brought to you by betterhelp it can be
tough to train your brain to stay in
problem solving mode when you're being
faced with a challenge but when you
learn how to find your own Solutions
there is no better feeling and a
therapist can help you become a better
Problem Solver making it easier to
accomplish your goals no matter how big
or small if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try better help is an amazing
fantastic option it is convenient it is
accessible it is Affordable and it is
done entirely online get matched with a
therapist after filling out a brief
survey and switch therapists at any time
that's really what people love about
better help myself included is just the
ease of it you know it takes a few times
you're never gonna unless you're super
lucky you're never gonna match 100 with
the first therapist it's very normal to
like shop around do a couple sessions
here there until you find someone that
you really Vibe with because it's so
personal more personal than comedy
um so better help makes it super easy to
switch it up you can do phone sessions
video sessions text sessions any format
that you're comfortable with you they
also offer
really Affordable Services like
financial aid it's just really premium
you don't have to deal with any of the
awkward like personal things like in a
waiting room or meeting people in person
can be awkward better help is everything
when you want to become a better Problem
Solver therapy can help you get there
visit betterhelp.com toast to get 20 off
sorry to get 10 off your first month
that's better
help.com toast today to get 10 off your
first month betterhelp.com toast
so yes we got the blow up even though we
got nothing you're telling me the blow
up happened in the Sprinter the Sprinter
is strapped with GoPros at all times we
watch all the women like do nonsense and
they didn't have the footage
It's too convenient I honestly I don't
really I think maybe Kathy said some
stuff but they're making it seem like it
was so crazy with Lisa Rena as our only
reliable witness and she won't even like
say what was said
and I understand like Kathy was mad at
Kyle she probably said mean stuff about
Kyle
okay yeah and although you know we have
only Lisa Rena for the Sprinter but all
the women said Kathy was being like nuts
Kathy was probably drunk and [ __ ] mad
at her sister and she was acting weird
with the conga line and wanting to leave
and screaming at her sister I believe
all of that
no but only Kathy only people who want
to see Kathy taken down are saying she
was acting so wild Crystal who is a
friend of Kathy said she didn't see
anything if Kathy's making this whole
scene but not but not everyone went did
Crystal go to that club
okay
so that crystal said she didn't see
anything Sutton said Kathy didn't want
like wanted to do a conga line nobody
wanted to do it and then Kathy said to
Sutton come home with me if you don't
come home with me you're not my friend
okay like not a like messy drunk
Behavior
stupid like not anything that's like
World War III in Beverly Hills the only
people who are saying that Kathy was so
Insidious never seen anything like it
before is Rina
Diana
Erica Erica Kyle
Kyle is going off of what Rena told her
yeah so here's the thing with Kyle
I now kind of like getting the whole
picture so when Lisa Rena had the
absolute Gall to say that Kyle is more
successful and Rich and richer than
more famous than Kathy Hilton like I had
to just laugh like that was funny
um I don't think Kathy thinks of herself
in competition with Kyle but I think
Kyle thinks of herself in competition
with Kathy um you can't even compare the
two
um I do think that they haven't
accurately really told us what their
Kathy before this Kathy and Kyle had not
been on good terms for years and they
never really told us what that was about
it's not really about American woman it
all stems from the agency
Kathy's husband is like a maven of real
estate in LA
Kyla Mauricio got married Mauricio
starts to work for Rick
they really kind of gave Kyle and
Mauricio a life like a a something and
then years later he worked his way up
the company and he goes out and makes
his own company the agency I think he
takes a lot of business from Rick's
company I think it hurt Rick's company
um and that's something to get into a
real argument with your sister about
taking away someone's livelihood hurting
their livelihood when you went out on a
limb for Kyle's husband that I think is
what this all stems from honestly that's
why they weren't friends for many years
they've never really spoken about it I
was surprised they even alluded to it
last night Lisa
um
and Kathy has every right I'm sure
Kathy's husband [ __ ] hates Kyle and
her husband I'm sure he does
yeah so that's what it's really all
about and they can make us seem it's
about like American woman and Mom it's
not
I think that those things don't help
it's compounded out with a sister like
if we're on the outs about like a real
whatever business just like the agency
that happened and then you're gonna go
make a show about our life and I don't
agree with the way that you're depicting
things like that is a problematic yeah
and Lisa being like she's jealous of
American woman like uh why would any
other woman's not on the air no and I
think like Lisa's really forgetting that
Kathy Hilton is one of the richest women
in Hollywood her daughters are two of
the most famous iconic socialites
um of all time and they're still at the
top of their game and the most relevant
I think she's forgetting like the Hilton
Enterprise while it doesn't still you
know own the Hilton Hotels is one of the
biggest names in real estate like Lisa
Reno really needs to get a grip that was
like a crazy delusional thing to say
and just made it seem like so obvious
like what they're trying to do
I I think Kathy probably has a temper I
think for sure
most people don't see and you know you
go on a girl's trip and you're drunk and
people are disrespecting you day in and
day and one of them is your sister
and you reach your breaking point one
thousand percent
um
but I don't without proof or quotes or
anything like nothing that Lisa Rin is
telling me makes it seem like anything
other than like she had a really bad
night
and that's that yeah and it's very
possible that Kathy said horrible things
that I wouldn't agree with but until I
have any sort of proof Lisa Rinna is
just not known for being an accurate
Storyteller she's known for being a
drama queen she's known for being
extremely biased extremely literally was
being such a soap opera Opera actress
whoever said in last episode I think was
garcelle like you would need an exorcism
to remove the soap actress from Lisa
Rinna like that when she was leaving
crystals last night I just feel like I
need to go home
the drama
like she still wouldn't say what Kathy
said like Crystal had no idea what the
[ __ ] she was talking about like it was
giving Crystal being like yes yes I
can't say it and everyone was coming at
Crystal being like you can't say
something like that and not give us
details Lisa you can't say something
like that and not give us details even
the text messages to Erica were
extremely vague we never what did she
say
okay she wants to take down NBC and take
down Bravo okay she hates her sister
she's mad at that sister Tings
yeah no that's like she's having a
really bad night but nothing in there is
like she's this evil plotting no and
everything that she's mad at Kyle for
like seems innocuous but when you put it
all together and like you you know how a
sister should be there for you like if
Kathy's having a bad night and she's
wasted and something's like wrong and
she's like Kyle I need you to take me
home and she says no if you ever came up
to me at a club with a group of friends
you're like Claudia I'm not okay like
you need to come home with me now I'd be
like all right I'll call the Uber like
that's what friends do and that's what
sisters [ __ ] do right and after all
day I'm being disrespected all day being
disrespected and like and Kathy's
Kathy's older you respect your older
sister
the conga line like sounds stupid but it
was just like one more thing where
everyone is just dismissed
yeah they're just the Casa del Sol
dismissive everything is like Kathy's
crazy Kathy's cuckoo they're making her
out like she's a mental patient
yeah
Justice for Kathy until I see anything
that even remotely disproves otherwise
yeah I'm so not convinced it would take
a lot to convince me because I I don't
believe a word that comes out of this
around his mouth
so that's a problem right so I'm
definitely biased I can own that
because Erica's very ready for it to be
someone else's turn as she's playing
she's basically saying like all right my
worst moment but you know what your
worst moments were caught on cameras and
I don't think
Kathy would have said any of that if the
Splinter Sprinter had been wrapped up in
cameras they were officially cut for the
day
yeah
and I think Diana is interested in being
the number one girl in this group and I
think Kathy's really the only one giving
her a run for her money yeah and you
know what the in terms of uh Prestige
and money the more they try to take
Kathy down the more tacky and gross they
all look and poor and the more elevated
and sickening Kathy becomes the way I
would lay my life out on the line for
Kathy is not normal considering I
actually I have met her twice
um and both times I was really impressed
with what I saw
also next week Lisa Rena like goes to
Kathy's house and it's like black heart
oh you're gonna show up with with more
Kettle also Lisa Rena let me tell you
something about release Arena if Lisa
finds herself in a situation where
someone's exposing themselves and
there's not a camera why isn't Lisa Rena
pressing record right and just if you
ever find yourself
between two sisters just know you are in
the wrong this is none of your [ __ ]
business get out
and I love how Kathy and her
confessionals was like yeah no I was
being like drunk and crazy I didn't
think that and you know Lisa was so
great she was so sweet to me and
understanding it was a great
conversation like I love her Serenity
and calm when Lisa's like I think I have
to go home
I loved it it's like making Lisa look
like such a drama queen which she is
yeah I just think that if Lisa Rinna
heard what she heard like she would have
recorded it because that's Lisa Rinna
yeah she's texting Erica she can text on
her phone but she didn't hit record so
true and I love Kathy like yeah I'll get
my own plane
I'm Kathy Hilton for [ __ ] sake
and it's about time everyone starts
[ __ ] acting like and stop treating
her like you know crazy old grandma
yeah
like the way I'm so team Kathy like and
I don't want anything bad to come out
because I'm obsessed
yeah that would be hard but it's at this
point they actually they're doing
themselves in the service because now
what needs to come out needs to be so
bad bad unforgivable unexcusable as
opposed to if we got like some quotes
she threw a cup you apologize move on
she threw her glasses I'm gonna take the
majority down
so I need more until I nothing Burns I
need more it was a big nothing burger
and the party made me say it kind of
makes me want to re-watch
the Kim and Kyle love it all because
back then like Kim was so painted as the
villain because she was the one like
going through stuff so it's like how can
Kim be wrong I mean how can Kyle be
wrong when Kim is the one you know who's
drunk and now I'm just like I feel like
I might have been seeing like the
Richards family Dynamic so wrong
I had when all I never cared I know like
I I wasn't I really didn't like him as a
wife but I was never like a Kyle Stan
and I feel like it wasn't until like
everyone took down Lisa Vanderpump and
like Kyle like engendered herself into
like this next Generation with like
dorit and Erica that I was like oh my
Kyle's like right that's so true
um but you always like really loved Kyle
I just like I never really cared about
that drama back in the day it wasn't
mine no I didn't care either it just
like made me sad
like sisters
like fighting like that is terrible on
on TV it's terrible
and I feel like Kathy's very much like
our like our line of thinking like old
school like very Caroline Manzo like you
don't betray the family even if there's
something wrong you handle it in private
whereas Kyle's like well I'm gonna be a
good housewife and I'm gonna put it all
out there and it's like yeah no it's
like we share no no some things can be
kept private and I think family
discourse is for nobody's ears but but
the family
yeah
and but that's just me
yeah so
hopefully someone will start bringing us
yeah I need proof I need proof
um
and how Kyle I think this is how it
plays out how Kyle's gonna let Erica and
Lisa like try and Destroy her sister
that is unforgivable those are her best
friends if she said stop they would stop
yeah that's no like not okay Lisa Rinna
wants to take down Kathy Hilton and
Kyle's gonna let her do it
and Erica's going to help her but I'm
not I'm not I'm not I'm not we need to
show out in full support for Kathy
mm-hmm I actually didn't even look last
night to see what people were saying
people I believe are firmly team Kathy
great it's Lisa brunette does not make a
good hero she is not the hero of this
story she has never been the hero of the
story people do not believe her even the
ones that like her know she's crazy pots
during drama queen
yeah it's the soap actor yes
we need an exercise oh I did want to say
how much I really appreciated garcelle
owning the fact that like perhaps she
should have just given a heads up she
wasn't sorry about what she said but she
could have given her friends a friend a
heads up when they were spending the
weekend together and she was like you
know what I should have I'm sorry
I also like the way Erica I thought that
was done I think like last season like
she would have been like on commentary
she didn't even get into the news really
about what she said she was like I would
have liked to heads up I thought we were
bonding and hurt my feelings and I think
garcelle was like yeah and I think Erica
understands like this is just her job
and like not to take it personally like
I'm sure garcelle wanted to talk about
this like she wanted a [ __ ] hole in
the head like it's not comfortable and I
think she was really mature about it and
I loved that like she just took umbrage
with the not getting a heads up which I
totally agreed with
yeah like we're talking about in Aspen
that was the time I loved that do it you
could have done it and I I love they
loved the whole exchange it was just
like mature Queen's style mature Queens
so that is the recap that is our show we
have one more show
on Friday that's our last show of the
week and then we have no show Monday and
Tuesday right that's Rosh Hashanah
because of Rosh Hashanah so tomorrow is
our last show until Wednesday
um so just keep that in mind and I'll
see you guys on Saturday at my show in
Huntington Long Island thank you so much
for listening to the morning test the
Millennium Morning Show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube start watching us on YouTube
please don't forget to subscribe give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as podcasting where podcasts
can be found so that's Spotify
hope you guys have an amazing day and
we'll see you on Friday bye bye